لا تفعل سيناريو أو سكرابل تقابل
روبي البالغة من العمر أربع سنوات ولكن لا تطلب منها أن
تبتسم ابتسامتك هي ابتسامة جميلة أوه
جميلة جدًا أخت روبي شبيكلر وصديق
أختها حاولوا إعطاء
روبي برنامجًا تعليميًا حول كيفية الابتسام الآن افعل ذلك
بأسنانك
لا ، لا
تستمر فقط ، لا تحشر أنفك ،
لا تفعل ذلك مثل هذا
فك أنفك وابتسم في الواقع
كما لو كان الفيديو مرتفعًا ، مما
تسبب في ابتسامة ملايين الأشخاص ولكن
ليس روبي كما لو كنت سعيدًا ،
تقول أخت روبي إنها لاحظت أولاً ما
إنها تسمي الابتسامة المزمنة عندما
التقطوا بعض الصور العائلية ، لقد صنعت هذا
الوجه المبتسم الرهيب مثل الذقن المزدوج المزمن الذي لا يبدو وكأنه كان
سعيدًا على الإطلاق ، إنه شيء
يجده الآباء في كل مكان رائعتين ، كل طفل يمر
بابتسامة تشاندلر بينغ
من أصدقاء تشاندلر بينغ يحاولون  لكي تبتسم
لصور الخطوبة الآن تشاندلر تريد
أن تبتسم لنا ،
حسنًا ،
أصدقاء روبي وعائلتها لم يحاولوا جعلها تقول
الجبن لقد وضعوها
أمام المرآة ، لقد نجح شيء واحد فقط
ندغدغها أحيانًا للحصول على
ابتسامة جيدة  خارجها ،
قد تواجه صعوبة في الابتسام عند
الطلب لكنها أتقنت
حركة العين وانتظر حتى ترى
كشافك الغاضب لأنك لن تستمع إلى
جدتي روبي يمكن أن تبدو أحيانًا وكأنها
رمز تعبيري Grimace يأتي إلى الحياة.
قطة غاضبة
رأيتها ، نعم ، إنها قريبة جدًا بحيث
تضرب الظفر على رأسها ، انظر إلى تلك العبوس الثاقب ،
أصبحت غرومبي كات ميمًا
استمتعت بها بمجرد أن كانت فظيعة على الأقل لا
أحد يجب أن يخبر روبي بمسح تلك
الابتسامة عن وجهها  اقلب هذا العبوس
رأسًا على عقب Genie Mouse CNN New York
احتفل بأي شخص